[Music]
one on 20,000 years ago our ancestors
gave us arguably one of the first
nonverbal communication examples we're
not there to talk to them but just by
watching of these hundreds of images we
can picture their everyday life we know
what they care about and we know what
they were scared twenty-something years
ago we can still smell the crayons in
our bedroom we wanted to communicate by
drawing spacious or flying unicorns it
felt so natural and sometimes we honor
our ancestors doing it in the living
room wall moving into today I don't
think there's been a time where we've
used more visual communications to
engage two other people
last week one of the biggest tech
companies have is IPO and they did not
file a snap social network they file as
a camera and image company by now you
can get how strong for visual and the
power of visuals and there's many ways
to illustrate that but if we have to
pick a really simple example we'll
probably go this way does anybody wants
to answer that question you seem pretty
excited to people the visual of you so
much you understand in your library in
that try giving a presentation can be
nerve-racking after focusing all of our
attention on getting the verbal
communication right we sometimes just
decide to skip the visuals I'm here to
tell you why that is a bad idea
visuals are incredibly important and
powerful going back to the example on
the screen where you go back to the
example on the screen we recognize that
the image is just so much easier to
understand because our minds process
visual information
much more efficiently than we process
words in fact more than nineteen ninety
percent of the information information
transmitted to our brain is visual and
even more impressive our brain processes
images 60,000 times faster than it does
words that is very powerful CJ don't you
want to take advantage of the power of
visuals in your next presentation
visual aids can help your audience
understand and remember the content that
you discuss visuals provide emphasis to
what you say according to the study by
the US Department of Labor you can
increase your audience's retention level
significantly by appealing to more than
one sense at the same time three days
after a presentation a person that only
listens to the presentation remembered
only 10 percent of the information while
a person that experienced both the
verbal and the visual aspect of the
presentation remembered 65 percent I for
example will never forget Eric Schmitt
the content of Eric's midterm
presentation because I remember it one
specific slide where he compared himself
this is out that will always stick with
me we retain visual information much
more efficiently because images go
directly into a long-term memory while
words have to be processed by our
short-term memory images can create
emotional reactions allowing us to
connect the emotions to the content and
remember it better
what visuals are not only better for
your audience they're better for the
speaker themselves as well the use of
visual aids
influences the perception of the speaker
a speaker that is using visual aids is
perceived as better prepared more
Namek more credible and 43% more
persuasive
according to preempt now that is
possible that is powerful and we should
all take advantage of that sorry I
forgot what I want to say actually in
moments when you forget what you say
and you forget your train of thought
visuals or slides conserve as a reminder
to what you want to say similar to
administer keeping a flash card in this
Bible a speaker can use slides to remind
himself what he although wants to say
now I want to tell you please remember
visuals incredibly powerful and
incredibly important both for the
speaker and for your audience thanks
Toby
I certainly understand the power of
visuals and presentation but how do I
actually do that I am no designer in
fact my artistic abilities peaked in
third grade art class so luckily we've
distilled four simple strategies from
Nancy Duarte persuasive presentation
that even as business types can handle
and every framework needs a catchy
acronym so here's our stack just because
these four strategies are the building
blocks of your visual communication I'll
take this one at a time a storyboard one
idea for size T create sides people can
jump in three seconds a arrange visual
elements with care and finally C avoid
visual cliche let's start with a
storyboard one thought per slide
storyboarding is a way to organize the
sequin
visuals and concepts TV and movie
producers like Alison use that pervert
production to make sure their shots are
in a logical sequence presenters can
also find this helpful to determine what
they're going to say and how they're
going to say it before we open up
PowerPoint this does not have to be a
difficult process you can just jot down
your ideas I'm cities or a piece of
paper in fact here's the storyboard we
created for this presentation it's
important to limit yourself to one
thought per slide each idea deserves its
moment in the Sun and it's fine to use
simple text and images your doodles are
absolutely fine because this is not
meant to take a lot of time which
actually leads me to strategy number two
T create slides people can get in three
seconds this is important because
research shows audiences can only
process one stream of information at a
time so every second your audience is
reading your size is time they're
ignoring you research also shows that
audiences find extra visual elements
distracting which reduces your impact
add the presenter effective sides should
pass a glance which means if your slide
with a billboard and your audience is
driving down the highway they should be
able to understand your main message
with only a glance we have three tips to
create sides that pass this glance test
first
start from scratch instead of using the
defaults that PowerPoint smells like the
titles and text boxes start with a blank
slate and only add elements as needed
for your presentation like here
Toby started with a clear gloss that
Illustrated his main point which we need
a tip number two limit your text like
the five or six words that are on this
slide and finally tip number three
coordinate your visual limit yourself to
one or two fonts use a consistent color
palette and make sure your images are of
a consistent style this is important to
make sure your size are easily
digestible and understood quickly by
your audience and now I'll hand it over
to Dena to share our final two tips
Thank You Rachel so let's talk about the
third branch of the egg which is to
arrange or fly alamin with care how are
we doing that actually you can't direct
your audience in a way that you like to
and we have three techniques we would
like to share with you under this dress
the first technique is that you should
be very intentional with the flow within
one slide for example in this slide we
would like you to focus on the bigger
picture first and then the text let's
see the next slide
the fact is exactly officers here we
would like you to focus on the task
first and then the bigger picture the
second technique we would like to share
with you in to Youth Contract human eyes
are drawn to things that stand out so
it's very important for us to create
contracts for people to know where we
should focus then how are we creating
contrast who can create that by creating
variations in the
sighs proximity and color of one single
element let's see here we can our focus
is on the pencil which is placed upside
down and we can use this light to share
the story how do I not write off
standing out from the crowd the third
technique is to make your use of cell
whitening I know
perhaps like me you valued every single
face on a flight and like to make full
use of it actually
why face have power so I encourage you
to resist the temptation to fill up your
face with every single world because
additional content can actually distract
the audience to hear I guess we are
having a great example of illustrate the
power of white base because we have that
in blessing now website for the very
philosophical answer that Jade always
gives on binoculars since we have
already discussed about how we are
ranging slide elements so what kind of
image or visuals we should use on site
our suggestion is that the four
strategies for visual reshape how are we
doing that whenever you think about the
concept you will like to illustrate the
first visual that comes to mind please
just forget it
why because that is something that
everyone can think of if everyone can
think of what is creation now right so
let's try a few samples
what is the first video that come to
mind when we talk about partnership
thank you exactly thank you so much more
partition I had a shake you from wall
but actually that is very cliche that is
not depends so what we with the job here
is to use a visual of the reach I hope
this dump which demonstrates
partnerships in your life your way
that's right now one let me talk all
security what is 40 made
that helps your life oh yeah that's all
for me and hikers but I'm feeling like a
hundred times everyday liking my
security cards to get into Highland Hall
but why not use the image of Doberman
where the email is even only protect you
family but also anticipate the danger
and threat so I forget a little bit
about history we talked a little bit
about science and we show you a catchy
framework we hope that you can find that
inner designer everyone has to bring it
out in your future business
presentations and saying that we would
like to open it for questions now
[Music]